c'est déjà reçu des messages d'étudiants
qui me disaient j'ai pris l'habitude de
me coucher tôt parce que le soir je ne
mange pas et du coup j'ai faim donc je
me couche tôt pour pas ressentir la faim
il ya une fois une personne qui m'a dit
que certains mois elle doit choisir
entre s'acheter des protections
hygiéniques ou s'acheter à manger que
c'est pas des cas isolés c'est des cas
extrêmes oui mais c'est pas des cas
isolés c'est vraiment beaucoup de monde
est de plus en plus de monde surtout
depuis qu'il ya le coc vide
[Musique]
on a tous en tête je pense les images
défilent d'étudiants qui attendait de
distribution alimentaire et c'est quand
même une image qui est dramatique en
fait quand on sait qu'on est dans un des
pays les plus riches du monde c'est un
petit peu étrange que je vais dire mais
pour moi la nourriture c'est pas juste
la nourriture c'est énormément d'autres
problématiques autour j'avais pas juste
envie de créer un simple site de
recettes j'avais envie de créer plutôt
un outil un outil qui permet de
s'alléger un petit peu de toute la
charge qui peut être lié au repas parce
que notamment quand on est étudiant et
surtout quand on a peu d'argent c'est
beaucoup beaucoup de charges
là on va faire un moine bottes pasta
donc en fait le principe de cette
recette c'est que il faut juste une
casserole donc moi c'est une casserole
avec des bourreaux et en fait on va tout
mettre dedans donc on va mettre les
pattes on va mettre les légumes on va
mettre la purée de tomate on va tout
faire cuire ensemble et à la fin on
invitera les eaux
c'est vraiment moi le plat est étudiant
par excellence parce que il ya besoin
que d'une casserole que d'une seule
plaque et c'est vraiment n'importe
quelle personne débutante en cuisine
peut le faire et ça marche avec un petit
monde tout ce que vous avez dans votre
frigo en fait maximum dans quinze
minutes c'est fait
oui j'étais étudiante en psycho mais
j'ai fait un décrochage scolaire et donc
pendant premier confinement j'ai arrêté
les études et à ce moment là le fait en
plus d'être confiné comme beaucoup de
gens je me suis mise à cuisiner plus et
donc je m'étais créé un premier compte
instagram où je partageais des recettes
et c'était dur combat mes recettes
habituelles donc vraiment facile rapide
adaptée aux étudiants et ça a eu un
petit succès en fait donc j'ai continué
pendant quelques mois je m'attendais pas
à ce que ça est vraiment du succès et
c'est là en fait que j'avais commencé à
recevoir les premiers messages
d'étudiants qui me disait que vraiment
manger c'était très compliqué pour eux
parce qu'il n'avait juste pas les moyens
en fait le succès qu'a eu mon compte ne
fait que montrer à quel point il ya un
problème à ce niveau là est un problème
auquel pour l'instant il ya passé une
solution satisfaisante qui sont
apportées
[Musique]
il ya eu beaucoup d'étudiants qui ont
posté des photos de leur repas à 1 euro
sur twitter et on pouvait voir qu'il y
avait une grosse inégalités selon les
établissements on a vu par exemple une
étudiante qui avait montré un sandwich
s'était littéralement un morceau de
baguette avec ma tête de transvider
mental je trouve que cette initiative
alors et dû être encouragés et être
amélioré en fait visé à faire en sorte
que peut-être travailler avec des
nutritionnistes pour que leur parent
euros soit vraiment pensé pour couvrir
les besoins réels des étudiants
[Musique]
j'essaie vraiment de proposer de ne pas
des plats qu'ils soient qu'ils soient
sains qui soit équilibrée mais ça a ses
limites en faisant ses études là
j'aimerais pouvoir maintenant me dire
que je donne la possibilité aux gens de
manger pas cher tout en mangeant des
choses qui sont vraiment complète est
bonne pour leur santé sur instagram tu
vas tu as le mettre dans une à céder
tout pour que ça fasse beau ou alors
dans les faits tout le monde dans la
casserole parce que flemme d'avoir un
truc à la nuit